what if humanity grew to be so
technologically advanced that we were
able to leave our solar system and
spread across interstellar space would
we hop from one exoplanet to another
colonizing everything in our way how
could we make travelling across the
universe possible and what would our
space civilization look like this is
what if and here's what would happen if
humanity became an interstellar society
no human has ever been outside of our
solar system and only a few of us have
actually left the earth even those who
blasted out of here in a rocket didn't
go too far there are billions upon
billions of planets out there but
they're so far away it would take us a
very long time to reach them if we
jumped into the fastest spacecraft ever
built it would take us over 70,000 years
to get to our neighboring star system
Alpha Centauri
even if we could accelerate a spaceship
to 99% the speed of light over 26,000
years would pass until we arrived at the
center of our own galaxy and another 2
million years until we set foot in the
nearest neighbor the Andromeda galaxy
how could we go about expanding our
civilization into space if we're so
terribly slow to become an intergalactic
civilization we'd need to break the
speed limit of the universe but for all
we know traveling at light speed is
physically impossible never mind
outperforming it the universe is
enormous possibly infinite and our
lifespans are too miserably short to
cover those kind of distances even at
near light speeds but let your curiosity
take over and imagine we were a
civilization that could approach light
speed and travel among stars we'd start
with Alpha Centauri our neighboring star
system who knows maybe the exoplanet
orbiting this 3 star system would turn
out to be habitable
then we'd push ourselves out further to
discover the billions of other worlds
not all of them would be suitable for us
to settle in
in astronomy a habitable world is a
planet that is just the right distance
from its Sun like star to be able to
sustain liquid water but the reality is
humans require so much more than that
atmosphere gravity temperature they're
all important it's unlikely that we'd
find another planet just like Earth but
we could build self-sustaining
earth-like biomes on our giant
spaceships where humans could live for
generations
or we could terraform some rocky
exoplanets first we'd harvest water from
a few ice comets then we'd alter the
planets atmospheres to resemble Earth's
anything to be able to breathe in fresh
air again even though space would be so
accessible people wouldn't travel around
the universe much once the new colonies
were established even at the speed of
light it would take generations to make
a trip to the other side of the universe
space is just too vast remember in this
new world
you'd get to travel among stars only if
you were a part of a ship's crew a
colonist or a space miner we'd send
robots to perform our intergalactic
chores robots don't eat sleep earn go to
the bathroom they can withstand high
levels of radiation and extreme
temperatures all the things that would
kill a human being but if space travel
is something you crave consider pursuing
a career as a postal carrier because the
most reliable way to communicate might
be through the mail surprised well our
satellites rely on radio waves to
transmit information even though these
waves traveled just as fast as light
they lose their strength over long
distances it's like being too far away
from your Wi-Fi router if humanity did
become an interstellar society we humans
would end up spread out across hundreds
of light-years of space at least we'd
give earth a break and allow it to
recover from our mistreatment maybe we
don't have to go so far maybe we could
create a new society on artificial
planets that we built around the Sun but
that's a story for another what if
[Music]
[Music]
you